j'ai consulté une voyante non et vous
non rien incroyable ça me fait j'ai à
peine une voyante c'est pourquoi est ce
que j'aime bien en temps savoir ce qu'il
se passait dans
ses poésies très brièvement beaucoup
moins maintenant alors pour vous pour
voilà en fait ce qui était dingue c'est
que je vais pas dit qui j'étais je vais
refuser de donner ma date de naissance
et mon nom pas mon prénom parce qu'elle
pourrait l'appeler marceau google est
donc le tout comprend des loyers la
lumière des dix c'est bizarre je vois au
lieu de deux il ya du public est
basané
ya un petit basané c'est eric zemmour
[Applaudissements]
petit bassin des combats quitter le pays
parce qu'il n'a malheureusement pas si
oui alors oui alors et demi qui est un
être exceptionnel nora équipe et avait
émis mais eddy et elle me dit c'est
célimène
[Applaudissements]
et
donc elle être fait et elmaleh déroulée
votre histoire donc c'est vrai abidi
voilà brillant il régime exceptionnel
incroyable et eddy vous a pris sous son
aile non c'est vos protections et il m'a
dit et vous pourrez lui dire qui va lui
arriver un grand bonheur trajet c'est un
vrai papa
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr il va pas racheté le dada
et va racheter le dal
non vraiment je dis alors là elle a pas
dire dans combien de temps ce
qua non vie pendant six mois parce que
déjà
basané qui vous a pris sous son aile
c'est un mec bien je me suis déjà c'est
déjà bon signe il faut sauver cyril
pardonnez moi c'est pas la première fois
qu'un voyant oui mais en voyant et ya
l'autre claude alexis décalé c'était il
ya dix ans
depuis ses huit enfants
lors à nice bonsoir ça comment elle va
celle ci est elle va très bien c'est son
deuxième jour alors attention leur a dit
ce qu'il avait été très bien hier mais
le deuxième jour de tpm pdc comme le
deuxième jour de ce qu'ils ont fait le
malin on est sur une piste noire ont
néanmoins on est au god i et là bas
[Musique]
mais nous sommes donc aujourd'hui leur
alice attention à la pression je vous
met la pression on a l'habitude d'avoir
la pression oui allez ses avocates bien
sûr elle ne fait pas peur la pression du
fait pas peur moi aussi mais au bar
l'estimé leur alice tu n'entends ma voix
rien que ma voix
et paupières sont lourdes ça marche pas
trop la très lourde leur alice
laura lis tu va nous donner trois
lettres de l'alphabet
vas-y px zbx z
qu'est ce que ça vous n'êtes pas dans la
merde
parce qu'elle est elle m le hic ce
qu'est ce que c'est que le big z je veux
dire que c'est quelqu'un qui aime
l'aventuré fécond et mx vélo tout
terrain elle aime partir à l'aventuré ce
qui veut dire que laura lice a besoin d'
aventure ce qui veut dire que leur alice
et dans un marasme
professionnelle et sentimentale et pour
la sortir de là j'ai ramené mon meilleur
lieutenant
l'abominable homme de rungis
[Rires]
c'est vrai tout ça moi j'étais juste fan
de scrabble tu es parti loin non m si tu
n'aimes pas la psychologie
le rallye ce que faites-vous le matin
beaucoup de choses parce qu'en fait mes
matinées ne se ressemblent jamais quand
on est avocat on peut être rappelé à 6h
du mat pour une garde à vue away ou
avoir des rendez-vous à n'importe quelle
heure ce matin j'étais très contente que
cela dit parce que là le l'émission
d'hier s'est super bien passé vous
voulez quand même faire un remerciement
à toute l'équipe parce que j'ai été
tellement bien accueilli merci bouclant
est ce que tu es à moi t'as pas eu de
césar
[Rires]
non mais taper deux heures d'émission tu
vas pas de gonfler
on dirait qu'elle est l'objet on dirait
qu'à lui le césar du meilleur rôle
féminin mr deschamps deux minutes à
faire redescendre de tomber